hey guys I'm just McDonald and you are
watching the gist today I'd like to get
stuck into a subject pretty close to my
heart and discuss some seriously awesome
female protagonists in video games now
unfortunately it's still a fairly slim
selection given how long gaming's been
around but they say quality beats
quantity and we certainly do have our
fair share of that for the longest time
Lara Croft was essentially a male
fantasy with a nice behind the games
could enjoy in third-person perspective
fortunately over the years she really
has established herself as more than
just a tiny waist that were not
realistically be able to support her
enormous boobs Lara Croft began to come
into her own before Square Enix's reboot
of the series last year but the latest
episode took it upon itself to write out
Lara's origin story the struggles of a
young intelligent archaeologist who
finds herself in extraordinary
circumstances and has to adopt the
skills to overcome them is intriguing
and easy to sympathize with indisputably
Lara has traditionally been a sex symbol
and the controversy over whether she's a
good role model has been the gamut of
opinions but she was still one of the
first women in videogames who got to be
tough
Lara may have paved the way for tough
women in video games but I think that's
definitely one that takes the cake the
female version of Commander Shepard if
anybody watching played as male shep
exclusively I'd implore you to create a
fem shep and bring voice actor Jennifer
Hale into your next Mass Effect
playthrough I personally found the dude
ship acted incredibly monotonous and dry
at times whereas Hale really nails being
tough assertive and completely charming
at the same time whether you're playing
is fair and just or being a jerk fem
shep never feels unworthy of being the
baddest toughest person in the galaxy it
makes sense that the story revolves
around you because even though you're
surrounded by strong well rounded
companions female Shepard
always
with her spot-on characterization and
line delivery no one like sarcasm
commander I do I hate you I hate you
ma'am on my list of the next character I
seriously need to get around to
cosplaying as and one of my favorite
female protagonists of all time is
Beyond Good and Evil Jade
apart from being one of the few people
in the world who can seriously pull off
green jade is a photojournalist who
either takes pictures of little
creatures for money or takes pictures of
enormous governmental conspiracies to
sway the local Hillians out from
believing their lies and if that isn't
enough to get you onside she takes care
of orphans in her spare time the dating
profile basically writes itself like
every good protagonist jade has some
pretty complicated internal [ __ ] going
on which i won't spoil fear but she's
very good with a staff and sneaky when
she needs to be she's essentially a
bundle of Awesome all wrapped up with a
green bandana and maybe one day they'll
finally give her and all of us what
wedge hereby announcing Beyond Good and
Evil 2 second-to-last on my list and the
last character I did actually cosplay as
is the Matt and lovely Alice from
American McGee's games of the same name
sake in a word Alice is complicated in a
lot of words her family died in a fire
she's clinically insane and spends the
vast majority of her life in a parallel
universe which used to be the Wonderland
you see in typical Alice appropriations
but is now sort of mangled and full of
tar demons and giant bloodthirsty dolls
Alice is more than a reaction to her
circumstances though she's dark and
clever and the things she says are
wonderfully stubborn and full of eager
despite the fact that she's batshit
crazy then there's the fact that all her
weapons are household items gone bad
like a hobby horse which deals massive
blows or a pepper grinder machine guns
much like femshep and Jade Alice is
exactly the kind of protagonist you want
on your side when the big bad comes
King with a hospital and attitude it's
hard not to feel remarkably safe no
matter how dire the enemies or
remarkably terrified depending on which
side you happen to be on plus up with a
lady who already made an appearance on
an earlier gist episode alongside her
faithful sidekick hateful Brian she may
not have strength on her side but she
has so much else the nice thing about
April Brian is that she's basically a
normal girl also the chosen one but
that's later April is an art student
living in Venice in the not-too-distant
future when parallel worlds start
colliding and mysterious people start
calling on her to set things right in
the adventure of the longest journey
things are rarely smooth and she's not
always on board with her duty to be the
savior of worlds interestingly it's her
willingness to question her
circumstances but continue on for the
sake of others which makes her so
interesting and obviously some
completely badass since the vast
majority of the women on my list have
done their fair share of world-saving
be sure to let me know in the comments
down below who your favorite female game
protagonists might be and if you like to
come join me again next week
you